were there all along the idea
every decision what if anything is not
your liking I'll change it it's perfect
I couldn't imagine a lovelier farewell
feel well yes my 80th birthday well
you're not going anywhere are you yes
did I took the tablets an hour ago I'll
be gone by midnight
with you
I was crazy
you got with me in spite your family cuz
you were curious about black is that
what you think it was yeah I do
and I was curious about white once again
three men under different circumstances
nothing you'd probably tell me you have
boy much yes some horse [ __ ] I wish I
knew how to quit you then why don't you
why don't you let me be huh [ __ ]
however your feelings have changed
I will have to tell you you have been
witched me body and soul and I love I
love I love you and a voice to be parted
from him from this Dale then move not
while my prayers effect I take
us from my lips by thine my sin is
purged have my lips the sin that they
have to sin from my lips o trespass
sweetly urged give me my sin again yes
yes mmm ah quite right it is more let me
then have my lips the sin that they have
took
sin from my lips o trespass sweetly
urged give me my sin again
I'm working 365 letters
I wrote you every day for year yes
still isn't over
you